i do feel like and i'm sure anybody who
spend any time with me at all
privately or in these sessions knows
that there's a tension
between the psychedelic community which
is to my mind
an exiled tribe of scientists
the psychedelic community we're the
heirs of freud and jung but
booted out of the tent of science
because we dared to use the human brain
body as an
instrument and so the only place where
we can
gain shelter and comfort is at the
fringes
of new age religion but these are not
our people these people you know they
serve
strange gods and bizarre agendas and
we need to not lose our identity
among them because they play by
different
rules uh now maybe
you know somewhere in the history of the
world
through god knows what it means the
truth was actually
downloaded to somebody a messiah
a rabbi a buddha somebody or something
somewhere but i find it
unpersuasive that idea
because
because truth is so
contextually defined and precious that
even if that had happened
what good would it have done you and me
you know
we received these things hideously
deformed by the metamorph
the metamorphosis of historical process
i live intellectually in a simpler
universe than the one that
my experience has taken place in
in other words i could tell tall tales
of shamanistic strangeness
apparent telepathy impossible
coincidental occurrences even
transformations of matter and
i've seen all of these things but
never under controlled conditions and
never with anybody claiming they
understood what was going on
what i doubt is that anyone understand
stands anymore of what's going on than i
do
not because it's an act of
self-elevation
that i am so smart that's not the
thought the thought is
everyone is ordinary and it's incredibly
disempowering
to not realize this you know if you
think that
belongs only to the dalai lama and
somebody
else this is incredibly disempowering
the mushroom said to me once it said for
one human being to seek enlightenment
from another
is like a grain of sand
to seek enlightenment from another
the message my interpretation of that
being all grains of sand are capable of
seeking enlightenment
on their own damn steam you know i mean
not that you people around you don't
have something to teach you
but an understanding
in the person sitting next to you is not
your
understanding and so it does you
absolutely no good whatsoever
uh it is only it is only uh efficacious
and functional
if it's yours and and
so um
the primacy of the the prime the primacy
of direct experience
and one's own history and mathematics
and you know if you really study
mathematics we mentioned this the other
night
you even get your legs cut out from
under you there because you discovered
this thing called the incommensurability
theorem which shows that even
simple arithmetic can't be trusted
so it turns out you know even our
platonic faith
in some kind of philosophical super
space
out there that we're measuring
everything against that that's naive
really the only really real
thing is this incredibly
evanescent ever moving barely grasped
hardly understood
thing called the present moment as i
experience
it and you say well my god can you build
a metaphysics and an ontology
and a heuristic method on on that
what choice do you have nothing else is
as
real as that is you know
you if you if you know the language of
theoretical biology you know
that a human being an organism
is a chemical system with granted
other properties perhaps not derivative
from chemistry
but a chemical system that is riding
far from equilibrium it's in a kind of
it's there are different terms for it
it's a dissipative structure
or it's an auto catalytic hyper cycle
or it's undergoing autopilesis
but the basic concept is that it is
maintaining itself as a coherent
entity in a universe flowing toward
entropy
it's somehow making its way uh
the opposite direction and you know your
your consciousness is embedded in one of
these
dissipative which will
and apparently your consciousness will
cease
at a certain level of
this equilibrium of this system but then
when you draw back
further you see your consciousness is
simply the reshuffling of the genetic
deck of your ancestors and before you
existed
people potentially or partially
like you existed and after you exist
people potentially like
you exist so but this
this non-dissipative energy flow where
consciousness
and life and everything is going
on and is known through
feeling through not not because you're
embedded in it
but because you are it essentially it's
not something that you're embedded in
like a particle
it it is your your essence well then
that's all there
all that is given with certainty then
everything else is extrapolated outward
from that
through convention language
poetic intuition religious revelation
just projected discovery myth
so forth and so on but that's all so far
from this point of immediate experience
that's why
the to my mind although i don't think
we've ever put it quite this way before
the psychedelics are so important
because
taking a psychedelic drug is not like
reading a book
or even like moving to italy for six
months
or it is it is directly
and immediately addresses this thing
which you are
it becomes part of it because what you
are is metabolism
you know the way this trick is done
where this dissipative structure can
come into being
and then ride magically uh
away from the entropy point is because
as biological systems we take in
highly organized matter food
and we extract all the energy and
everything useful from it
and excrete it out and so
by this means we overcome
the the general drift toward entropy
metabolism allows
life to happen metabolism is
life in some sense well the drugs are
metabolized
you know this is a fairly intimate way
of relating
to a substance put it inside your body
and let it dissolve into every
uh every cell of your being
so metabolism is uh
is a like the primary domain
of communication it's the communication
mode of the filled presence
of the immediate experience and the
the drugs work there like foods
they're not that really that different
than
foods they you know like it says in the
jefferson airplane song
it feeds your hand i guess she was
actually quoting lewis carroll
but in any case it feeds your head
you